hello Internet in my last video about
Pluto you may have noticed that I said
aloud the names of every planet except
one this one and that was no accident
but rather the result of careful script
editing because where I grew up I
learned that the name of the seventh
planet is pronounced Uranus of course to
a kid
Uranus sounds an awful lot like Uranus
which is how I and everyone else I knew
ended up saying the name which is funny
when you're a child but becomes bit of a
problem when you grow up and try to
teach scientific facts about the planet
for example Uranus has a ring around it
astronomers have discovered a dark spot
on Uranus Uranus is a gas giants Uranus
is surrounded by methane there is a
solution to this problem the alternative
pronunciation of the name which goes
Uranus and most scientists in public
roles do use this pronunciation but for
me Uranus is still problematic sure it's
better than Uranus but it's still Uranus
and perhaps I'm just childish but when
someone else says Uranus I still hear
Uranus in my head and it just draws more
attention to the unfortunate name the
tragedy is it didn't have to be this way
the seventh planet from the Sun is
unique because it's the first planet we
discovered for all of human history the
six closest planets were big enough for
bright enough to see with just our
limited simian eyes but the next planet
was too dim to see until our telescope
technology got good enough for British
astronomer William Herschel to spot it
in 1781 understandably though he didn't
think he discovered a new planet since
from the rise of modern humans fifty
thousand years earlier until that
Tuesday no-one ever had but discovered
he did and so choose a name he must and
Herschel being the good subject of the
crown that he was christened his new
planet the Georgian situs which means
the Georgian star and the George in that
Georgian star was King George the third
the reigning monarch while King George
liked the name the rest of the world did
not and decided that perhaps Herschel
wasn't the best guy to name the new
planet after all and quickly decided to
come up with alternatives of their own
one suggestion was Neptune which is
confusing to us now but at the time the
planet that would become Neptune had not
yet been found the more obvious
alternative was to name the planet
Herschel after the man who discovered it
even in Great Britain the name the
george of sight has proved a bit stuffy
for some so variants like the georgian
planet or just georgia were also used
though never as you might have heard
george side don't hear while researching
this video i found a lot of websites
claiming that the seventh planet was
almost named George but I was
never able to find a primary source for
this as best I could tell searching
through documents from the time no one
ever suggested this name I checked with
the Royal Institution who since 1799 has
been promoting science awesomeness from
the part of London and whose videos you
should now go watch and they confirm the
name George was never on the table
because - so casually refer to the king
at the time would have been
disrespectful and disrespecting a
monarch is never a good idea especially
one who is slowly losing his mind from a
genetic disorder but that's a story for
another time anyway another real
suggestion for the new planets name came
from Johann bode who suggested the Greek
god of the sky when a colleague of Voe
discovered the 90 second element in 1789
he named it uranium to support bones
choice and trine and the debate perhaps
because these two were German it might
not have occurred to them how the word
would eventually be corrupted in English
though it's also hard to know how
English speakers in the 1780s and 90's
would have pronounced the name but since
the word anus was in the language then
it seems unlikely that this particular
pronunciation would have been popular it
may also have been pronounced with a
flat a to sound like Uranus or something
more like the Greek name Muranos these
names competed with each other over
decades for example still in 1823 the
Encyclopedia Britannica lists the planet
as partial notes the alternative names
and then proceeds to carefully word the
rest of the article to avoid naming the
planet again but you a dear modern
viewer know that eventually these
alternatives faded and left this name
triumphant which leaves someone like me
with my terrible pronunciation longing
for history to have taken a different
path the name Herschel might have made
the planet sound a bit like a boring
accountant rather than the very
interesting planet it actually is but
this would still be a much better name
than what we have the Neptune is
obviously a fine planetary name though
picking this might have just delayed the
problem finally the George M situs is a
bit awkward and in sillier moments I
wish that Herschel had just been more
direct and named at King George
because how fun would that make it to
teach kids the list of planets today
Mercury Venus Earth Mars Jupiter Saturn
King George and Neptune in classroom
such an unusual name would change the
planet from a thing to avoid to a
starting point for discussions about
what makes that planet different and how
astronomy and our view of the universe
change and progress over time but my
practical dreams aside we're stuck with
his name which for me means choosing
between the pronunciation which comes
naturally and is terrible or the
unnatural awkward one which is still
unsatisfied
so what's a man to do in the end
probably follow the lead of the
Encyclopedia Britannica and avoid the
name when possible which is a sad fate
for the planet in our solar system with
such an interesting story to tell
Uranus seriously people could we at
least agree to switch the pronounciation
back to the Greek who knows it's clearly
so much better